Khan Academy is most known for its its
collection of videos so before I go any
farther let me show you a little bit of
a montage so the hypotenuse is now going
to be 5 this animals fossils are only
found in this area of South America nice
clean band here and this part of Africa
we could integrate over the surface and
the notation usually is a capital Sigma
National Assembly they create the
Committee of Public Safety which sounds
like a very nice committee notice this
is an aldehyde and it's an alcohol start
differentiating into effector and memory
cells a galaxy hey there's another
galaxy oh look there's another galaxy
and $4 is there 30 million plus the 20
million dollars from the American
manufacturer if this does not blow your
mind then you have no emotion
we now have on the order of 2,200 videos
covering everything from basic
arithmetic all the way to vector
calculus and some of the stuff that you
saw up there we have a million students
a month using the site watching on the
order of a hundred to two hundred
thousand videos a day but we're going to
talk about and this is how we're going
to the next level but before I do that I
want to talk a little bit about really
just how I got started and some of y'all
might know about five years ago I was an
analyst at a hedge fund and I was in
Boston and I was tutoring my cousin's in
New Orleans remotely and I started
putting the first YouTube videos up
really just as kind of a nice to have
just kind of a supplement for my cousin
something that might you know give them
a refresher or something and as soon as
I put those first YouTube videos up
something interesting happen or actually
a bunch of interesting things happen the
first was the feedback from my cousin's
they told me that they preferred me on
youtube than in person and and once once
you get over the backhanded nature of
that there was actually something very
profound there they were saying that
they preferred the automated version of
their cousin to their cousin at first
it's very unintuitive but when you
actually think about from their point of
view it makes a ton of sense you have
this situation where now they can pause
and repeat their cousin now they can
without feeling like they're wasting my
time they could if they have to review
something that they should have learned
a couple of weeks ago or maybe a couple
of years ago they don't have to be
embarrassed and ask their cousin they
can just watch those videos if they're
bored they can go ahead they can watch
it at their own time at their own pace
and probably the the least appreciated
I guess aspect of this is the notion
that the very first time the very first
time that you're trying to get your
brain around a new concept the very last
thing you need is another human being
saying do you understand this and that's
what was happening with the interaction
with my cousin's before and now they
could just do it kind of in kind of a in
the intimacy of their of their of
our own room the other thing that
happened is you know I put them on
YouTube just just you know fur for the
you guys I saw no reason to make it
private so I I let other people watch it
and then people started stumbling on it
and and I started getting some comments
and some letters and and all sorts of
kind of feedback from from random people
around the world and you know these are
just a few this is actually from one of
the original calculus videos and someone
wrote just on YouTube it was a youtube
comment first time I smiled doing a
derivative and let's let's pause here
this person did a derivative and then
they smiled and then in response to that
same comment this is on the thread you
could go on YouTube and look at these
comments someone else wrote same thing
here I actually got a natural high and a
good mood for the entire day since I
remember seeing all of this matrix text
in class and here I'm all like I know
kung fu let's see and we got a lot of
feedback along those lines you know
that's clearly was helping people but
then as the viewership kept growing and
kept growing I started getting letters
from from people and it was starting to
become clear that it was actually more
than just a nice-to-have that this is
just an excerpt from one of one of those
letters my twelve-year-old son has
autism and has had a terrible time with
math we have tried everything
viewed everything bought everything we
stumbled on your video done decimals and
it got through then we went on to the
dreaded fractions again he got it we
could not believe it he is so excited
and so you can imagine you know here I
was a an analyst at a hedge fund
I it was very strange for me to do
something of social value
I was a
but uh I I was excited so I kept going
and then a few things other things
started to dawn on me that not only
would it help my cousin's right now or
these people who are sending letters but
it could may be that this content will
never go old that it could help their
kids or their grandkids if Isaac Newton
had done YouTube videos on calculus I
wouldn't have to sue sue assuming he was
good we don't know the other thing that
happened you know even at this point you
know I said okay maybe it's a good
supplement is good for motivated
students it's good for maybe home
schoolers but I didn't think it would be
something that would somehow penetrate
the classroom but then I start getting
letters from teachers and the teachers
would write saying we've used your
videos to flip the classroom you've
given the lectures so now what we do and
this could actually happen in every
classroom in America tomorrow what I do
is I assign the lectures for homework
and what used to be homework I now have
the students doing in the classroom and
I want to I want to pause here for
I want to pause here for a second
because there's a couple of interesting
things one when those when those
teachers are doing that there's there's
the obvious benefit there's the benefit
that now they're there students can
enjoy the videos in the way that my
cousin's did they can pause repeat at
their own pace at their own time but the
more interesting thing this is the
unintuitive thing when you talk about
technology in the classroom by removing
the one size fits all lecture from the
classroom and letting and letting
students have a self-paced lecture at
home and then when you go to the
classroom letting them do work having
the student the teacher walk around
having the peers actually be able to
interact with each other these teachers
have used technology to humanize the
classroom they took a fundamentally
dehumanizing experience a bunch of
thirty kids with their fingers on their
lips not allowed to interact with each
other
a teacher no matter how good has to give
this kind of one size fits all lecture
to thirty students you know blank faces
slightly antagonistic and now it's a
human experience now they're actually
interacting with each other so once the
Khan Academy kind of you know I quit my
job and we turn into a real organization
or not-for-profit the question is how do
we take this to the next level how do we
take what those teachers were doing to
their natural conclusion and so what I'm
showing over here these are actual
exercises that I started writing for my
cousin's the ones I started were much
more primitive this is a kind of a more
competent version of it but the paradigm
here is well we'll generate as many
questions as you need until you get that
concept until you get ten in a row and
the the Khan Academy videos are there
you get hints the actual steps for that
problem if you don't know how to do it
but the parrot I mean it seems like a
very simple thing ten in a row you move
on but it's fundamentally different than
what's happening in classrooms right
right now in a traditional classroom you
have a couple of a homework homework
lecture homework lecture and you have a
snapshot exam and that exam whether you
get a 70% at 80% and 90% or 95% the
class moves on to the next topic and
even that 95% student what was the 5%
they didn't know maybe they didn't know
what what happens when you raise
something to the to the zeroth power and
then you go build on that in the next
concept that's analogous to imagine
learning to ride a bike
and I give you a bicycle maybe I'll give
you a lecture ahead of time and and I
give you that that bicycle for two weeks
and then I come back after two weeks and
I say well let's see you're having
trouble taking left turns you can't
quite stop you're you're an 80%
bicyclist so I put a big C stamp on your
forehead and then I say here's a
unicycle but as ridiculous as that
sounds that's exactly what's happening
in our classrooms right now and and and
the idea is you know you fast forward
and students start good students start
failing algebra all of a sudden and
start failing calculus all of a sudden
despite it being smart despite having
good teachers and it's usually because
they had these Swiss cheese gaps that
kept building throughout their
foundation so our model is learn math
the way you would learn anything like
the way you would learn a bicycle stay
on that bicycle fall off that bicycle do
it as long as necessary until you have
mastery the traditional model it
penalizes you for experimentation and
failure but does not expect mastery we
encourage you to experiment we encourage
you to failure but we do expect mastery
this is just one another one of the
modules this is trigonometry this is
shifting and reflecting functions and
and they all fit together we have we
have about 90 of these right now and you
could go to the site right now it's all
free not trying to sell anything but the
general idea is that they all fit into
this knowledge map that top node right
there that's literally single-digit
addition it's like one plus one is equal
to two and the paradigm is once you get
ten in a row on that and it keeps
forward you to more and more advanced
modules so if you keep so it keep this
further down the knowledge map or
getting into more advanced arithmetic
further down you start getting into
pre-algebra and early algebra further
down you start getting into a Algebra
one algebra to a little bit of
precalculus and the idea is from this we
can actually teach everything well
everything that can be taught in this
type of a framework so you can imagine
and this is what we are working on is
from this knowledge map you have logic
you have computer programming you have
grammar you have genetics all based off
of that core of okay if you know this
and that now you're ready for this next
concept now that can work well for an
individual learner
you know and then I encouraged one for
you to do with your kids but I also
encourage everyone in the audience to do
it yourself it'll it'll change what
happens at the dinner table but what we
want to do is use the natural conclusion
of the flipping of the classroom that
those early teachers had emailed me
about and so what I'm showing you here
this is actually data from a pilot in
the Los Altos School District where they
took two fifth grade classes and two
seventh grade classes and completely
gutted their old math curriculum these
kids aren't using textbooks they're not
getting one-size-fits-all lectures
they're doing Khan Academy they're doing
that software for roughly half of their
math class and I want to make it clear
we don't view this as the complete math
education what it does is and this is
what's happening in Los Altos it frees
up time this is the blocking and
tackling making sure you know how to do
with a system of equations and it frees
up time for the simulations for the
games for the mechanics for the for the
robot building for the estimating how
high that hill is based on its on its
shadow and so the paradigm is the
teacher walks in every day every kid
works at their own pace and a teacher
get this is actually a live dashboard
from Los Altos School District and they
look at this dashboard every row is a
student every column is one of those
concepts green means the students
already proficient blue means that
they're working on it no need to worry
red means they're stuck and what the
teacher does is literally just says let
me intervene on the red kids or even
better let me get one of the green kids
who are already proficient in that
concept to be the first line of attack
and actually tutor their act their peer
now
I kind of come from a very data-centric
reality so we don't want that teacher to
even go and intervene and have to ask
the kid awkward questions Oh what do you
not understand or what do you do
understand in all of the rest
so our paradigm is to really arm the
teachers with as much data as possible
really data that in almost any other
field is expected if you're in finance
or marketing or manufacturing and so the
teachers can actually diagnose what's
wrong with the students so that they can
make their interaction as productive as
possible so now the teachers know
exactly what the students been up to how
long they've been spending every day
what videos have they been watching when
did they pause the videos what did they
stop watching what exercises are they
using what have they been focused on the
outer circle shows what the exercises
they're focused on the inner circle
shows the videos they're focused on and
the data gets pretty granular so you can
actually see the exact problems that the
student got right or wrong red is wrong
blue is right the leftmost question is
the first question that the student
attempted they watch the video right
over there and then you could see
eventually they were able to get ten in
a row it's almost like you can almost
see them learning over those last ten
problems they also got faster the height
is how long it took them so you know
when you talk about self-paced learning
it makes sense for everyone you know
education speak differentiated learning
but it's kind of crazy what happens when
you actually see it in a classroom
because every every time we've done this
in every classroom we've done over and
over again if you go five days into it
there's a group of kids who've raced
ahead and there's a group of kids who
are a little bit slower and in a
traditional model if you did a snapshot
assess but you say oh these are the
gifted kids these are the slow kids
maybe they should be tracked differently
maybe we should put them in different
classes but when you let every student
work at their own pace so we see it over
and over and over again you see students
who took a little bit extra time on one
concept or the other but once they get
through that concept they just race
ahead and so the same kids that you
thought were slow six weeks ago you now
would think are gifted and we're seeing
it over and over and over again it makes
you really wonder kind of how much all
of the labels maybe a lot of us have
benefited from we're really just due to
a coincidence of time now as valuable as
something like this is in a district
like Los Altos our goal is is to use
technology to humanize not just in Los
Altos
but kind of on a global scale well
what's happening in education and
actually that kind of brings an
interesting point is it you know a lot
of the effort in humanizing the
classroom is focused on student to
teacher ratios in our mind the relevant
metric is student to valuable human time
with the teacher ratio so in a
traditional model most of the teachers
time is spent doing lectures and grading
tests and whatnot maybe five percent of
their time is actually sitting next to
students and actually working with them
now hundred percent of their time is so
once again using technology not just
flipping the classroom you're humanizing
the classroom I'd argue by it by a
factor of five or ten and as valuable as
it is in Los Altos imagine what that
does to the adult learner who's
embarrassed to go back and learn stuff
that they should have known before
before going back to college imagine
imagine what it does to a kid a street
kid in Calcutta who has to help his
family during the day and that's the
reason why he or she can't go to school
now they can spend two hours a day and
remediate or get up to speed and not
feel embarrassed about what they do or
or don't know now imagine what happens
where you know we talked about the peers
teaching each other inside of a
classroom but this is all one system
there's no reason why you can't have
that that peer to peer tutoring beyond
that one classroom imagine what happens
if that student in Calcutta all of a
sudden can tutor your son or your son
can tutor that kid in Calcutta and I
think what you'll see emerging is this
notion of a global one-world classroom
and that's that's essentially what we're
what we're trying to build thank you
huh
time okay
I've seen some things you're doing in
the system that have to do with
motivation and feedback energy points
merit badges tell me what you're
thinking there oh yeah no we have an
awesome team working on is not and I
have to be clear it's not just me
anymore I'm still doing all the videos
we have a kind of a rockstar team doing
the software yeah we've put a bunch of
game mechanics in there you get these
badges we're gonna start having
leaderboards by areas and you get points
it's actually been pretty interesting
just the wording of the badging or how
many points you get for doing something
we see on the system-wide basis like
tens of thousands of like fifth graders
or sixth graders going one direction or
another depending on what you know that
bad you give them and that collaboration
you're doing with Los Altos how did that
come about
yeah don't los altos been kinda it was
kind of crazy they once again I didn't
expect it to be used in classrooms
someone from from their board came and
said oh what would you do if you had
carte blanche in a classroom and I said
well you know I would just every student
work at their own pace on something like
this we'd give a dashboard it you know
and they said oh this is kind of radical
we have to think about it and I mean the
rest of the team like oh you know
they're never going to want to do this
but literally the next day they're like
can you can you start in two weeks yeah
okay so it's fifth-grade math it's four
that's point two fifth grade classes and
to seventh grade classes and I think
they're doing at the district level I
think what they're excited about is they
can now follow these kids it's not an
only in-school thing I mean we've even
you know on Christmas we saw some of the
kids we're doing and we can track
everything so they can actually track
them as they go through the entire
district through the summers as they go
from one teacher to an X you have this
continuity of data that that even at the
district level they can see so some of
those views we saw were for the teacher
to go in and track actually what's going
on with those those kids so you're
getting feedback on those teacher views
to see what they think they need oh yeah
actually most of those were were kind of
specs by the teachers we made some of
those for students so they could see
their data but you know we have a very
tight design loop with the teachers
themselves and their lure saying hey you
know this is nice but I like that focus
graph a lot of students a lot of the
teacher said I have a feeling that a lot
of the kids are jumping around and not
focusing on one topic so we made that
focus a diagram form so it's all been
teacher driven it's it's been it's been
pretty cray
is this ready for primetime do you think
a lot of class classes next school year
should try this thing out yeah it's
ready it's you know it's uh we got a
million people on the side already so we
can handle a few more and it's uh it's
no no reason why why it really can't
happen in every classroom in America
tomorrow and that the vision of the
tutoring thing the idea there is if I'm
confused about a topic somehow right and
user-interface I'd find people who are
volunteering maybe see their reputation
and I could schedule and connect up with
those people absolutely you know and
this is something I recommend everyone
this audience to do is you can that
those dashboards the teachers have you
can go log in right now and you could
get you can essentially become a coach
for your for your kids your nephews your
cousins or maybe some kids at the Boys
and Girls Club and yeah you can start
becoming a mentor tutor really
immediately but yeah it's all there
well it's amazing I I think you've just
got a glimpse of the future of Education
thank you thank you
you